هذه المجموعة من النشطاء خربشوا ذات مرة
غضبهم على الحواجز حول هذه
الوزارة
الآن يريدون تحدي
الحكومة في صندوق الاقتراع
في عام 2015 ، كنا هنا ، نعم كنا لا نزال
أطفالًا ، وكان معظمنا
أطفالًا واليوم نواجه نفس الجدار و
نحن نقدم أوراقنا لتصبح
حزبًا سياسيًا
يسمونه حزبهم السياسي بالنعناع
مما يعني
أنه ينتشر باللغة العربية فقد ولدت
من رحم انتفاضة شعبية في خريف عام
2019 ،
أدى الوباء وعدم إحراز تقدم
إلى إنهاء المظاهرات الجماهيرية
لكن الغضب ضد النخبة الحاكمة ، الذي
يُنظر إليه على نطاق واسع على أنه فساد ،
ينهار لبنان في
ظل واحدة من أشد
الأزمات الاقتصادية في العالم ،
وهناك زخم هنا لتحدي
المؤسسة ، كل هذه
المجموعات السياسية الصغيرة تطفو على السطح
، وتتلاشى ، ويتلاشى البعض
الآخر.  حاول اكتساب الشرعية التي
يقودها شباب لديهم
خبرة قليلة وموارد قليلة
لكن النشطاء يقولون إن هذه هي الطريقة التي يبدأ بها التغيير
من العشب  لهذا السبب
يقول منتشرين إنهم بدأوا في حشد الأصوات
خارج
بيروت مركز السلطة نتبعهم في
رحلة ليوم واحد إلى قرية باثا الصغيرة
في شمال البلاد.
شباب ليبراليون
من العاصمة
لكن رئيس البلدية يقول إن لديهم
شيئًا مشتركًا
بغض النظر عما إذا كان هؤلاء الحكام السياسيون
يستطيعون تحقيق أي شيء
نحتاجه ، نحن بحاجة إلى وجوه جديدة ،
أخبرني أن
كل مواطن لبناني يجب أن يكون جزءًا من
انتخابات الثورة
المقرر إجراؤها في مايو 2022.
كن أول
اختبار لضريح النعناع ومجموعات
مثله وهناك تعبئة ضخمة محتملة حيث
بلغت نسبة المشاركة حوالي 50 في المائة
خلال الانتخابات الأخيرة ،
فالخط الأول بالطبع يعمل
نحو الانتخابات البرلمانية
لإعلام سكان هذه القرى
بوجود
شباب جدد  الأحزاب التقدمية التي يقودها والتي
يمكنهم الوثوق بها في المستقبل
ولكن هذا يشبه معركة ديفيد
وجالوت  ما هي فرصة وقوفك حقًا
ضد النخبة الحاكمة لديك
مليشيات في
كل مكان عندك فصائل مسلحة لديك
سياسي طائفي أه أحزاب
لكن هذا ديفيد كما تعلم
قد بدأك تعلم لكن مع قليل من
الأساطير والمعجزات فقط الوقت يمكن أن
يسقط العمالقة
الذين لديهم  حكمت هذه الوديان لأجيال
ط